if we switch to women what do women want
they want
also physical appearance for short-term
mating yeah phys physical attractiveness
what else uh well some cues that
represent physical attractiveness that
maybe represent health well here's this
is your
i'm learning a lot here yeah well so but
you're also asking a very interesting
question about uh what is a
controversial within the evolutionary
psychology
field right right and not totally
resolved so that's why you're on the
sixth edition of the book and there
could be a lot more questions coming
yeah i revised it every four years or so
because there's four years of um new
interesting work and so it deserves
updating but
the
traditional i should say uh
answer to your question is that women go
for good genes cues to good genes in the
short term
and
cues to resources in the long term and
this has been a hypothesis that
advocated i didn't come up with this
this one um
by um
steve gangstad a former student of mine
marty haley from randy thornhill and
some other um
very smart players in the field
and
and what they used as
markers of good genes or things like
symmetrical features uh and masculine
features so
strong jawline high shoulder to hip
ratio
um
you know other other sorts of masculine
features
but i started to doubt this
explanation for what women want in the
short term
um because of some other
findings so for for women a lot of
short-term mating is not
one night stand mating so
but rather it's
a fair mating
so uh so if you ask the question why do
women have affairs
so let's restrict the question for the
moment
my colleagues would argue well women
have affairs because they're trying to
get good genes from one guy
while in they're getting investment from
the regular partner the husband
okay but the problem is that when women
have affairs
uh 70 plus percent tend to fall in love
with or become attached to their affair
partner
now outside what percentage 70 yeah 70
some large majority yeah
or more in contrast to men where it's
more like 30 percent of men who have
affairs
fall in love with or become attached to
their fear partner
so but from a design perspective um an
engineering perspective if you will uh
that's a disastrous thing if you're just
trying to get good genes so you're
trying to retain the investment of one
guy yeah while getting good genes
surreptitiously
from this you know guy who presumably
has one
falling in love with them becoming
attached that's that's not a feature you
want yeah it's bad engineering
yeah exactly it's bad engineering and so
and so i developed an alternative uh
hypothesis that i call the mate
switching hypothesis
which is that
affairs are one way in which women
divest themselves of a a cost-inflicting
partner or a partner who
things aren't working out well with and
it's a way to either transition back
into the mating market or to or to trade
up in in the mating market
uh and and so
anyway so these are these are probably
the two leading hypotheses about why why
women have affairs and i
am putting my money on the mate
switching hypothesis um
my
esteemed colleagues are putting their
money on the good genes hypothesis but i
think the evidence for the good genes
hypothesis is starting to um
look shakier than initially
but this is a heated debate i mean made
squishing sounds like a so from a game
theory perspective from an engineering
perspective seems to make a lot more
sense unless you put a lot of value
in lifelong sort of in the long term
mating
some kind of
value in the um
lifelong singular relationship like
monogamy
yeah
and maybe we do psychologically maybe
there's a big
evolutionary advantage to that and we we
do but we also know that divorce is you
know um and breakups are are also common
and occur in all cultures so yeah um so
we're just not very good at this thing
well either we're not good at the main
selection
such that
uh maybe we're
not incorporating
all the variables well or we're just not
good at monogamy period
from an evolutionary perspective well i
think they're
that's
a debate no that's raises an interesting
set of questions so i think that
i mean one issue is is longevity so i
mean we didn't live
to be 70 80
years old
and over 99 of human evolutionary
history and so we didn't necessarily
evolve to be
mated monogamously with one person for
decades and decades and decades
but i also think that
long-term pair bonding is a critical
strategy but mate switching is also a
critical strategy so if you have a mate
for example who um
becomes cost inflicting or becomes
sufficiently debilitated or who
um
suffers uh an injury such that like in
hunter gatherer societies where the mate
can no longer hunt can no longer provide
resources for
their kids and and and the woman
this becomes this becomes a problem and
so uh and so i think that we have
adaptations to mate switch and
to divest ourselves from
some partners and trade up in the mating
market under certain conditions
so okay and those conditions will differ
from men and women what are some of the
cues
in terms of what women want
um you know go to the gym
so a hotly contested debate you said
evolutionary psychology and this is uh
in the uh bro psychology forums that i
visit uh multiple times a day and now
i'm just kidding uh what what's the most
important cue of appearance
for guys um
what muscle group is the most important
to work on to women care about biceps is
what i'm asking in terms of physical
appearance um
uh
a a good um
shoulder to hip ratio so
relatively wide shoulders relative to
hips um
is is one
women tend to prefer men who are
physically fit and
well toned but not
muscle bound so like if you go to oh i
don't know someone like
those early when arnold schwarzenegger
was
doing the
mr whatever it was contest you see the
women don't find those attractive the
extremely muscle-bound guys
but they like
a guy who's physically fit
high shoulder-to-hip ratio
they like guys who are physically taller
than they are
um and guys who are a bit above average
in in height so
if the average so if uh
you know the average is i don't know
five nine five ten and out there for
humans depending on the culture women
prefer an inch or two taller than that
um so um so shoulders
height
dad bod
wha what's that about why don't why why
do you want a dad bot what why do you
why why not how do i define what what is
a dad bod dad bot is not muscle bound
okay so out of shape a little no no no
just a little bit
a little bit of uh
cushion for the pushing i don't know
what the kids call it these days uh but
just a little bit a little bit of a fat
so what's why do they not want uh guys
to be obsessed with their body is that
or is that some evolutionary thing
yeah i think that um
women
might interpret a guy who is so obsessed
with his body that he's uh they might
view that as a sign of narcissism yes
um and that's not a good trait
uh
what about like cultures where
large sort of overweight men are valued
is that how do you explain
like how much can we override the
evolutionary desires with our sort of
cultural
fashions of the day that maybe represent
other
desirable aspects like wealth well
wealth is
resources have always been important
especially to women so is a man
able to acquire resources and is he
willing to dispense them to her and her
kids so that's always important in
traditional cultures that boils down to
hunting skills so
if uh so i have to uh call a friend kim
hill who's uh probably the world's
leading expert on the aceh of paraguay
and uh and you asked him like what what
leads to high status in the aceh in
males hunting skills that's that's nice
one the one thing the big variable and
that's resources and that's resources
now what's what's interesting about
modern cultures we have cash economies
but cash economies are relatively recent
and
you know historically there's over the
vast
99 of human evolutionary history you
weren't able to stockpile resources in
the way that you are today
um
although there are interestingly certain
ways you can do it so so like you you
kill a large game animal okay you bring
it back you get some status points
because you
give some to your family you can share
it more widely with the group et cetera
but
but it's going to go bad right you can't
just say i'm going to keep this carcass
around for the next several months okay
but
and and i think okay i think it's a
steve pinker who might have used coin
this phrase that they they store the
meat in the bodies of other people and
so for example they store it in their
friends so
you know um
hunting success is uh
you know it's it's a hit or miss kind of
thing so you might come back
empty-handed four times out of five
but and but when you do you share your
meat with others and then when
you know and then they reciprocate by
sharing their meat with you and so and
so you can store resources in the bodies
of other people which is i think an
interesting way to think about it but
that can only go so far and when you
have cash economies you have both the
ability to stockpile resources but also
this kind of explosion and
um inequality of resources
and that's evolutionarily recent what
about now this is the difference between
the hubermann the excellent hubermann
lab podcast that you did that people
should listen to
he is a brilliant scientist a um
sort of
uh
a rigorous analyst of what is true in
the scientific community also helps you
with great advice on how to live now in
contrast to that i am a um
a terrible
uh
almost idiotic level journalist so this
is what you have to deal with
another thing that people talk about
that women care about is penis size does
penis size matter for women in sexual
selection
well um there's controversy about that
in the evolutionary psychology community
well i is there papers on penis size i
wouldn't say
uh scientific paper so speculations um
about
in nature or in science yeah yeah no
nothing nothing that i've seen there
um
you know i i think that there's
individual variability um so uh this is
something that comes up again you know
when i ask women in the class my classes
you know what do women want some will
say you know a large penis
but i think there's variability
in in
that preference and it also might depend
in part on the variability in
the woman's anatomy
so
um do you think there's something
fundamental in terms of evolutionary
psychology in terms of evolution or is
this a quirk of culture that's current
that's maybe somehow connected to
pornography or something like that yeah
my my guess is it's it's something
that's uh
perhaps a quirk of culture or or
something that is
evolutionarily recent
um but um but but i don't know i mean
it's a topic that hasn't been explored
much i've never done work on it and well
somebody should do a phd uh sort of some
archaeologist should do a phd on the
history of
human civilization
and its uh evaluation of penis size and
and the correlation of penis size to the
value of the male
okay
moving on another absurd question in
terms of what men want
again definitely not a huberman lab
podcast question
why do men
let's say a large fraction of men love
boobs
well uh i think that uh
you're one of the uh most cited
evolutionary psychologists
and this is what you signed up for this
is these kinds of questions questions
like this yeah yeah well so again this
is something i haven't studied directly
but um
uh
scientifically yes yes uh but um but
yeah there's been some work on that and
and it's uh another cultural court
perhaps no i don't think it's a cultural
quirk because i think it's the uh
the shape
that matters a lot because
shape is going to be a cue to fertility
uh and
so one of the things that humans are
attracted to in the opposite sex is
sexually demorphic features and breasts
are a sexually dimorphic feature and the
morphic
difference between
difference in morphology between males
and females got it
um
diminishing to morphic morphology
uh so um
and women don't develop uh
breasts until um
puberty or post puberty
uh and and so uh as a sexually demorphic
characteristic we tend to be attracted
that same is true by the way with the
waist to hip ratio that we mentioned
earlier
uh prior to puberty males and females
have very similar ways to ratios but at
puberty um there's a differential
uh
hip development and fat deposition that
creates a sexual dimorphism uh with
respect to waist tip ratio and so again
that's
men are attracted to this waste of ratio
that no man consciously says that they
find this woman more attractive than
that woman they don't think ah she has a
waist up ratio of 0.7 oh that's exactly
what i do but anyway most men most men
yes
so
isn't that fascinating that we just
build these entire industries the
fashion and what we find beautiful
around
these kinds of ideas and we just
and then
not just not just fashion and then we
build
uh west's
uh sociological tensions about whether
we should care about this kind of thing
or not
there's there's battles in that space
it's like
they seem so simple it's just the human
body and we wear clothes first of all
that's that's a funny thing what what's
the why are we wearing clothes what's
the shame aspect yeah of covering up the
body is that another feature or is that
what is that yeah that's that's that's
an interesting question and i i don't
know it's just like hiding uh ovulation
maybe that's another hiding like uh
maybe hiding is a great game theoretic
thing to play with because it can give
you it can give the powerless more power
by covering well well maybe well i think
there are a few things so one is
the sort of arbitrary features of
fashion and then the other is the
aspects of fashion that attempt to um
magnify uh what is inherent in our
evolved standards of beauty
so for example
women tend to wear things that
accentuate their waist hip ratio
so i mean
historically those
in the old days corsets for example
cinch the woman's waist
and you wouldn't see fashion develop in
a way that made a woman seem
old unhealthy
um uh
pockmarked uh signs of
open source or lesion
there are certain domains um design
spaces that you wouldn't that no culture
would develop
um
so but there are arbitrary features but
sometimes they're not entirely arbitrary
or they're arbitrary at one level of
description but not another
so for example
fashion
tends to be linked with status
and that's why it constantly changes
the high status people start wearing a
certain type of
clothing
uh and then when the lower status people
imitate them then they have to shift to
signal their status and so i think the
fashion and clothing is in part linked
to status